[Applause]
Thanks so my talk is going to be about
fast spectral algorithms from sum of
squares analyses so let me just write
out the title
and one really nice area of development
in some of the squares recently has been
a bunch of sum of squares algorithms for
what David termed machine learning
problems ok so this is stuff like you
know tensor decomposition and tensor
completion and all kinds of learning
problems like community detection
dictionary learning etc right and you
know something really really nice about
these I suppose algorithms is that
they're really really strong so they saw
the harder problems meaning like for
many of these problems are some
parameter like sparsity and as you
ratchet up the sparsity the problem gets
harder so so like you know if the
problem is super super sparse you can
solve it pretty easily but then as you
increase the rink it gets more difficult
and sum of squares can achieve
algorithmic guarantees for much higher
ranks so this is especially is just one
one example I just thought that would be
familiar thing for people and then also
there they're really robust so in the
sense that for learning style problems
you know oftentimes you're trying to
learn some distribution ok
and the more samples you have the the
lower your signal-to-noise ratio will be
right but there's this cost to gathering
more data so sum of squares lets you
work in settings where there is much
more noise than previous algorithms have
allowed you to do ok so so this is this
is really nice and you can think of this
as a proof of concept that these
problems are in fact in polynomial time
ok which is really awesome because we we
didn't know that before but there's a
small drawback which is the this is
pretty slow ok so like what do I mean
like slow like like say that's we're
thinking about you know some some
learning problem like maybe dictionary
learning so you're solving an SDP in n
to the maybe six variables okay so you
know sometimes you don't know that it's
six but sometimes it is six
right and so you have into the six
variables and and n is like the number
of features so like maybe if you're
trying to learn something about
photographs okay the number of features
is like the number of pixels in your
photograph
so that's like make a you know like a
pretty modest estimate that maybe this
is like you know 10 to the 4 ok so then
like you know 10 to the 4 to the 6 that
many variables when you're solving STP
that's like a like a really you know
burly AWS instance right like that's not
something we can really hope to run and
and so you know one would say well maybe
you can get something additional out of
these SMS algorithms maybe you can take
the insights that were developed when
analyzing these algorithms and transfer
them into spectral algorithms or
something more lightweight that you can
actually hope to run in practice ok so
so so in fact there have been a couple
of works about the subjects where you
take an SOS analysis and you get for
made a fast spectral algorithm
okay and and by fast here I mean like
definitely sub-quadratic time and
sometimes even near linear time and let
me just list a couple of papers so the
first kind of work on this topic was by
Sam and myself and Jonathan Chi and
David store in 2016 for the average case
sensor decomposition and some other
problems and then there's a follow-up
work by Monta nari and son from the same
year about tensor completion
so both of these works are based on sum
of squares analyses that use primal-dual
analysis right and so you're doing some
kind of spectral primal-dual analysis in
these two works you can sort of bypass
that and and turn that into a spectral
algorithm yourself so I'm being like
super vague right now like but
essentially these work through the dual
okay but today I'm going to focus on a
newer work which is joint work with
David that does robust tensor
decomposition
okay and kind of the the difference
between these two works and this work is
it here we're really really working in
the primal space okay so it's kind of
like a new strategy for SOS speedups
probably if I draw down here it's too
low to see
okay so I'll move up here so so let me
just outline very very like bird's-eye
view what the what the strategy is here
and then I'll say more precise things
okay so for these tensor decomposition
problems the best sum of squares
algorithm solve an SDP of the following
thing so I have some input tensor T and
what SOS will do is it will solve a
maximization problem max X T where X is
some matrix all right and then there's
going to be a bunch of other constraints
for now for now like I mean you know
actually this this is true for every
order tensor that we know but but for
now like let's say it really doesn't
matter because we're in such an abstract
place that you know it could be any any
order so okay so so we have the this SDP
and we're trying to find a point that's
correlated with T and satisfies all
these constraints or you could also
think of this as we have some set of
convex constraints
and we have our input tensor T and we're
trying to project T into the
intersection of all the constraints
okay so this is what the STP is doing
that CP computes this projection right
and then what we do is we take this
projected point and we apply a rounding
algorithm
and as we're analyzing the rounding
algorithm we'll use all kinds of
properties of these convex sets that
were Noah we know that we're in the
intersection of right so this is like
you know what always happens basically
but and like the really expensive step
was this step right where we said okay
we really care about all of these convex
constraints and we're going to compute
the projection into their intersection
but actually ultimately in the end maybe
we didn't use properties about every
single one of these constraints when we
analyzed the algorithm okay maybe we
could have gotten away with much much
less and also maybe we didn't have to
just directly compute the projection
into the intersection maybe we could
have done this in an iterative fashion
that would have been less expensive so
that's that's exactly what we do so what
we do is we choose some key constraints
that were important in the analysis of
her rounding algorithm
yeah just these two we take our same
starting point T but now what we do is
we compute the projection iteratively
right so maybe we we first compute the
projection to the nearest point in this
constraint 0.1 okay and then we project
down to the next second point right and
then what we're gonna do is we're just
going to hand off to the same rounding
algorithm and because we more or less
satisfy all of the properties that we
use when we analyze the rounding
algorithm for the STP solution all right
algorithm is still gonna work okay so
this is a way to avoid that CP solve
because each of these projections are
just going to be like fast sum of area
spectral algorithm projections
extra information about normal fixes but
like X minus T squared has this inner
product but outside the norm of X is
quite obvious that it having this
projection
no X X is the thing that we're X is our
variable of our program right so we can
constrain the norm of X however we want
okay you know it's not like a I'm not
sure that you could formally like maybe
it's not like exactly formally
projection but but you know close enough
we should we should maybe talk off
offline so okay anyway this is this is
like the you know the the high-level
overview of what's supposed to be going
on okay so so in the remaining time I
want to tell you about the robust tensor
decomposition algorithm and I sort of
took like when I was planning this talk
an extreme position on the like accuracy
and precision versus you know
information scale so like like I'm going
to try to convey as much information as
possible but it might not feel very
precise so at any point like please stop
me and make me give you the details or
like tell you I'll give them later okay
but but first of all I guess I should
start by telling you what tensor
decomposition actually is so let's see
okay so let's start with actually what
is a tensor alright so a tensor is just
going to be a higher order array of
numbers so like a 3 tensor is the
maximum size of the tensor that can draw
but actually today we'll be working with
4 tensors just because even order
tensors are nice the order is the sort
of number of dimensions
and and the dimension in the tensor so
we'll be working also with completely
symmetric tensors right so I assume that
each of these guys is an N by N by an
array and I'll have n of them
this is an order for tensor
okay I'll have the entries be in the
reels
and a fact that's true about tensors
that sort of generalizes facts that we
know about matrices is that I can write
such a tensor as a sum of rank one
tensors
and when the tensor is symmetric I can
write it as a sum of symmetric rank-one
tensor sorry this should be before where
the VI are vectors in RN
okay and um here is the rank of the
tensor and something that is true for
matrices but is not true for tensors is
or I guess something that the tensors
don't do is it's actually np-hard to
compute such a the the minimum Rank 2
composition in the worst case
I guess I didn't say that but the tensor
decomposition problem is to find the V
eyes or vectors that are close to them
in l2 norm and whatever sense that you'd
like yeah so these are symmetric tensors
actually the algorithm that I'm talking
about today can also be applied to a
symmetric tensors although in the paper
it's not written up this way but yes and
I think the same might be true for the
sum of squares algorithms if you're
willing to take a hit in a degree but
yeah let's assume symmetric tensors I
mean this is already an interesting case
yes yes
um yes so so computing computing such a
decomposition is np-hard in the worst
case so it's this differs from matrix
decomposition which is sort of like
finding the singer value decomposition
but in the cases when you can find the
VIS so in many cases of interest you'll
get a bonus over matrices which is that
the decomposition will be unique right
so like in the matrix case if I have a
matrix M say that UV transpose is like
its singular value decomposition right
it's also true that I can put any
rotation and its inverse in the middle
and this is also a perfectly valid
decomposition okay but but for tensors
this will not be the case right like
many times in our cases of interest the
de comenzar to be unique and that's what
makes this a like important primitive in
many learning problems so this this
uniqueness like kind of gives you it's a
nice property so okay
any questions about entry to competition
yeah I mean you know I don't like to put
like a yeah I sign here if I want but it
shouldn't change anything for today but
let's not let's ignore them because it
will make things notationally more
difficult okay so so this problem is
np-hard in the worst case but for
specific types of tensor decomposition
for specific types of sensors we know
algorithms okay so okay maybe here also
you already notice that you know this
was average case sensor decomposition
and robust sensor decomposition
basically there are many different ways
that one could try to take you know the
tensor decomposition problem and find
like the edge of tractability right so
but let me let me start it like the you
know very safe interior of tractability
so an algorithm that's been known since
the 70s is yen Eric's algorithm
okay and let's let's assume that we're
in the following case so an aurochs
algorithm has guarantees for the final
case so the the vectors v1 through VN
are orthonormal
okay so unit norm and orthogonal so in
this case Yin arcs algorithm applies and
the reason that I'm telling you about
Yonex algorithm is it this is actually
this rounding algorithm that both SOS
and us ultimately will pass off to okay
but also it's like a really basic
algorithm that's nice to see so so what
am I gonna do I'm gonna take my my input
tensor T okay it's this sum of VI tensor
fours and I want to find these guys I'm
gonna think of it as a big tall stack of
matrices like a N squared high stack of
matrices
and let me for you know notational
convenience call the a beef slice here T
sub a T so in B our numbers between one
and n and what I'm going to do is I'm
going to sample N squared
iid gaussians
okay and I'm just going to compute the
matrix which is the sum of the scaled
slices so some gabgab okay so just a
random contraction okay no it turns out
that this ta B is secretly equal to sum
over i from 1 to m VI a times VI P times
VI di transpose so like I don't want you
to think about this too careful you know
this is just like a syntactic fact that
you can verify for yourself but what
that means is that if we look at this
sum here this is equal to the sum over
the vectors now G inner product so this
is the N by n matrix right which is the
sum of these orthonormal vectors with
random independent coefficients so now
if I compute the singular value
decomposition of this n by n matrix I'm
going to exactly recover the V is right
I mean because these will be independent
gaussians and and they're not going to
be the same value with probability one
basically okay so then I pass off to SVD
okay and then I'm done
so that's that's a nice algorithm and
it's very very nice for the orthonormal
case there's one really serious drawback
which is that this is not at all robust
to noise okay so so let's see why so
so let's say that I also want to have
I'm not given tea but I'm giving T which
is equal to or TT twiddle let's say
which is equal to T plus some noise
tensor e ok and ok so like obviously I
can't make a just whatever I want
because then we would be in this np-hard
case right so so let's say that I make e
like I'm gonna make some pretty
reasonable worst-case assumption on e so
I mean I'm also going to introduce some
pretty non-standard notation here so
remember E is an order for tensor I'm
going to call a sub a little square to
be the N squared by N squared flattening
of the sensor
wait this is a block matrix and into a
beef block I'll put the matrix e a B
okay and similarly I'm going to use the
e sub rectangle notation okay which is
the same thing but this is the N by n
cubed reshaping okay so so maybe like
one reasonable assumption that I can
make is I can make the assumption that
the spectral norm of the square shape
navee is its most Epsilon for some small
constant epsilon right so this is
actually allows me to capture many
different settings but but also it's a
it's a reasonable constraint on e to
make sure that I don't get into any of
these hard cases so okay so suppose that
this is the case so now because this is
a linear operation right if I take if I
apply a onsens auger the earth sorry and
Rex algorithm to t tilde I'm going to
get some over a B JB little a B which is
just the same as applying it to T into e
separately right so here I get the nice
thing
I think that was us sitting off the
okay so this is this is our old friend
from that board over there but here the
problem is that if you use matrix
concentration to bound what the spectral
norm will be like of this of this term
it's going to be something like square
roots log n times the spectral norm of
the rectangular reshaping of the instead
of the squaring shaping of e with high
probability and this guy can be as much
as epsilon square root n okay so if we
make this assumption there are
situations in which we get a spectrum of
epsilon squared and here and what that
means is that if we want this term to
dominate the signal term to dominate the
noise we need this Gaussian to be at
least root n log n which is a
exponentially unlikely event right so
the hope would be to you know be able to
still handle this case
but let's that's I mean of course
opposed to matrix that's a very small
not mean a very small proportion of
tensors that what you have this
orthogonal decomposition and if you have
nobody's you will probably fall into you
know regime where you're not retiring
with decompose the goal is to find T T
itself so you know like the setting you
should have in mind I should have said
this in the beginning is that T is what
is it's like the moment tensor of some
distribution okay and T tilde is
something that we got by taking the
empirical moment tensor right and so you
know is some noise and and if we take
more and more moments we can control its
spectral norm but it might have some
some you know systematic errors as well
right but but still what we want is the
true moment moment tensor and that
should be given by T
so how close to exact can this get yeah
so let me let me write down the the SOS
theorem start okay so okay so here's a
theorem
so this theorem due to Tanguma and
Jonathan Chi and to David if it in that
case so if we get T tilde which is T
plus E and the spectral norm of the
squarish aping is gonna do a epsilon
then degree six SOS can recover
you won through um such that you I enter
product VI squared is at least one minus
Epsilon
it's one - order epsilon okay so you can
get pretty close with Alice before the
VI orthogonals before
okay so so already I think this is
pretty surprising because you know here
we didn't make any strong assumptions
about the noise like in some sense we're
in the worst case noise model right it's
not like iid entries or anything like
that okay so so now I'll say very
briefly something about this algorithm
so the algorithm works by writing down
the following relaxation
so you want to find tensor X which is
close to T tilde your goal actually is
going to be recut to recover T itself so
now you put down all kinds of reasonable
constraints like you want the trace to
be N and you want the the tensor to be
positive semi-definite and it's square
reshaping you want the spectral norm of
the rectangle version to be at most one
and a button and a bunch of other SMS
constraints right but now you're only
going to crucially use two facts in your
analysis okay so the first fact is going
to be that X can't correlate very much
with E
right so so you prove this using some
some Samos squares analysis using your
constraints and then the second thing
that you so basically what this means is
that you have to be close to T so so one
more thing I should say is it a feasible
solution to this program is to just plug
in T there the objective function is n
right so what this actually implies is
that X and T correlate at least 1 minus
epsilon and which is large as a as a
fraction of the trace of X ok and then
the second thing that you're going to
use is you're going to use this the the
rectangle norm of X is small okay so so
basically what you do is you say okay we
have some tensor e that's close enough
to T right so that if I go and I apply
an aurochs algorithm to it I'm going to
recover one of the the vis and the
reason that we needed the rectangle
enormous friction is exactly for this
reason right so so you know on average
there'll be one guy that you're very
close to right and the rest will be
bounded in spectral norm so this is this
was very sloppy Avista that's the
general idea yeah yes yes yeah I just
wrote it here explicitly yeah I do mean
them and here I mean em everywhere I
guess let's make n equal to M
okay so
so why did why would that on the left
exist this the the thing with the
rectangle being less than yeah so so if
I take T itself right and I write down
its rectangular area shaping I get some
over I VI tensor 3 VI transpose right in
each of these is an orthogonal like
we're talking about all the others and
it has norm 1 so the spectral norm of
this is 1 okay so now I guess in a
couple of minutes remaining I'll say
what we do right so essentially what we
want to do is we want to avoid solving
this SCP but we want to still be able to
produce an object X which is not very
correlated with the noise and also has
small rectangular norm so what we'll do
is the following
so in our first step will take T twiddle
okay so T twiddle is is equal just to T
plus e but if we look at the inner
product of T twiddle with e this could
be approximately the same as just
looking at the Frobenius norm of e
squared right because you know T is
maybe negligible and Frobenius term
compared to heat and and here this is a
rank n squared matrix right even though
the spectral norm is epsilon so this
could be something like epsilon N
squared
which is which is too much for us right
we only want order M or n correlation so
so what we do is we say okay well let's
look at the spectrum of T twiddle so
these are the eigenvalues so because
it's essentially a rank n matrix of
eigenvalues one with a perturbation
added to it like a small perturbation we
know that this is going to look like
this so it'll be n eigen values that are
close to 1 and then all of those will be
epsilon square you shaping and what we
do is we just we just say okay we don't
like we don't need any of these eigen
values right so we just compute the
first and eigen values of T twiddle and
we keep those so that's like the T prime
be equal to the T twiddle square greater
than Epsilon I hope this notation is
clear okay and and now what you want is
you want to prove that T prime is close
to T so how do you do this well let's
look at the distance between T and T
Prime
so this is it most the square root of
the rink
at times the spectral norm very shaping
right here I took the difference of two
rink and matrices so this is at most two
N and here I can just use triangle
inequality right so I compared T 2 T
twiddle that's it most epsilon and then
I compared T prime to T twiddle right so
that's also at most epsilon because I
just removed a bunch of eigenvalues
value epsilon should I write out the
triangle inequality or everyone yeah
okay all right so this is it most 2
epsilon maybe right so here I can bound
this by say 4 epsilon and it's okay and
the reason I am it's it's actually a
good that you're pointing this out so
I'm really strongly using the fact that
I know that T was a Rankin matrix and I
also know that T prime is an incan
matrix and so their difference couldn't
possibly have rank higher than 2 n yeah
but generically it could be as high as n
squared okay so so by this step we
achieve this first requirement
and and then what we do is we need to
accomplish this as well but what we're
gonna do there which is we're just gonna
compute the projection to the span of or
knots this fan we're just going to
compute the projection to this set of
matrices that have rectangular norm at
most one right so our second step is
going to be to let T prime prime be the
projection in l2 of T prime to K where K
is the set of matrices weight a spectral
norm in this one
okay and because T is already inside K
when I take T Prime and I project it in
l2 down to K to get T double Prime the
distance between T and T double prime
can only decrease so I will continue to
satisfy this property okay and then and
then we just hand off to you next
algorithm in exactly the same way that
the sum of squares algorithm did and I
guess there are a couple of subtleties
there are many subtleties so one thing
is that you know this is good enough for
getting one component right so to get
one component we now spent time you can
verify this later in the privacy of your
own home so so if you do all the careful
analyses of how much time each of these
spectral projections took it will take
time into the Omega plus two where Omega
is the matrix multiplication constant
right so so let's pretend that that's
two so all right so this is like but but
the input has size n to the four right
it's a it's an order for tensor so this
is like nearly linear in in the size of
the input but that's only for recovering
one component right and then you can
actually do this like n times or order n
times and you'll recover 0.9 of the
components faithfully but after that
because we sort of I mean here what we
did was was actually potentially pretty
damaging to some of the components right
and so we have to do a recursion
actually that's not different from what
the sum of squares algorithm does but in
the sum of squares land you can sort of
add extra constraints to your SDP that
say I don't want to be near any of the
components I already found and we in the
spectral lands can't do that so that's
where the additional complexity that
David mentioned in his talk really comes
from but but yeah I guess I guess I'll
conclude sorry for going over time maybe
I'll say one nice open direction is to
try to generalize this to the case where
your tensor is not orthogonal and you
actually have more than an rank higher
than n right so to over complete tensors
and there it seems like there are some
some obstacles which we don't know how
to overcome
[Applause]
if the noise is random he said over
space can you find the components
exactly I think not not that I know of
off the top of my head but you might not
need to do the recursion step s
algorithm doesn't find them exactly
yeah not that we know every yeah so yeah
why don't we only pull off one come on
it's so this I mean this has to do with
what I didn't tell you about applying an
aurochs algorithm to the SCP solution so
somehow this condition only tells you
that if you look at one component of T
it will be like the STP solution will be
at least like you know one correlated
with it right there the correlation will
be at least one and somehow that's the
one that you're going to recover in that
step right so even with the SCP actually
you have to run this iteratively like
when I analyze gender X algorithm over
here you know I used really strongly
that I knew exactly what this slice
looked like and I said look here's the
SVD right but when you don't actually
know exactly what slice is you have to
do something that's I mean it's not very
complicated but it's like you know you
apply Markov inequality to say there's
at least one guy that you're correlated
with and then you actually need the
Gaussian to be closer to that guy than
to the rest which happens with inverse
poly probability
I think you can get one yeah
I mean you don't write you really don't
know why right like it could I mean the
SDP I think there's nothing that
prevents it from picking one guy to be
close to and then all of the other guys
maybe it just ignores them entirely ursa
I mean I don't know I mean you know
you'd have to think about it more
carefully but I think you can only get
one at a time
[Applause]